Speaker 2: We're continuing our coverage of
some of the most important and consequential
races in 2022. One such race is the Georgia
Senate election. This is the race in which
Democrat Raphael Warnock is the incumbent.
And on the other side, very disturbingly,
Herschel Walker, former NFL football player,
is the Republican nominee. There is a new
series of videos of Herschel Walker at
some kind of event. And in this event,
you know, we've heard. Herschel Walker be
completely incoherent about the economy.
We've heard Herschel Walker be completely
incoherent about gun violence. We've heard
Herschel Walker be completely incoherent about
social media. Here he delves into issues of race
relations and the Constitution and what he refers
to as the 14th Amendment. Now, that is. That's
not my pronunciation. I want to be very clear.
But this is another one of these examples where
Walker looks visibly confused by the things coming
out of his mouth. He doesn't seem to know what
he's saying, and certainly no one in the room has
any clue what this guy is saying. And he is even
even in the polls with Raphael Warnock. This
is one of the most important races. Not only
is it important because if Democrats do hold the
Senate, it may be by only one seat. And if this
race doesn't go the way of Raphael Warnock, it
could be because of Herschel Walker. The Democrats
lose control of the Senate. It's important for
that reason. It's also important because this guy
is so unqualified to be a senator that it really
puts in serious relief. I guess I would say you
really feel the texture of how absurd the modern
Republican Party has become that they're willing
to vote for a guy like this. So let's listen
to this first clip about the 14th Amendment.
Speaker 1: I'm like, whoa. So from
all you read the Bible forgiveness.
Speaker 3: And I said, if you read the
Constitution and the 14th Amendment,
you know, Obama was apologizing.
Speaker 1: For the White House because
they say every man be treated fairly. But what is
happening? We elected the wrong people to office.
They began to talk about the wrong leaders.
Speaker 2: What do. You know what he just said?
If you read the Constitution, the 14th Amendment,
you know, our forefather was apologizing for their
whiteness because they say every man be treated
fair. But what has happened? We elected the wrong
people to office. That didn't pick up the baton
and run with it. I don't know what that means.
Speaker 1: Is they left the button on
there and complained about what was
happening rather than trying to fix it. Yeah.
Speaker 2: And the woman to his left nodding.
She seems to get it. I don't know what he's
talking about, guys. I genuinely don't. And
these are just the scrambled is the only
way I can describe the talking points.
Here's another example of this stuff. And you
know what? What is true is what has been pointed
out by some of our viewers. He's doing like
a red meat word salad. It's like it's like a
Republican red meat bingo where even if it's
completely scrambled in terms of its syntax,
there are individual words there that are
triggers to Republicans to get mad. We laugh,
but they're talking about a green agenda.
Speaker 1: They get mad at me cause I don't
want any more trees. I don't want police.
Speaker 2: All right. So this is like mixing
two things. Green agenda. Oh, that's very bad.
Very, very bad. And I want police officers. Oh,
yeah, yeah, yeah. We support the police. I mean,
okay, not the law enforcement officers that
handled the search warrant at Trump's house
and not the Capitol Police that were there
on January 6th. We don't support them. But as a
general concept, do we support police officers.
Unidentified: Although border patrol,
I wonder if somebody must. Ted Mack is
87. Arias agent.
Speaker 2: 87. Are
agents now? It's just a scrambled talking
point. You guys might remember there's this
talking point about Joe Biden's hiring
87,000 new IRS agents. Now, the truth is
55,000 of them are over the next period of time
because there's so many employees retiring from
the IRS, it's just to replace them. We'll go
over the details of those numbers Friday. But
the talking point is 87,000 IRS agents.
The talking point is a lie. And Herschel
Walker calls the talking point 87 agents.
Speaker 1: They're laughing because I say
trees. No, I don't want trees on police officers.
Speaker 3:
You know, what I want to do is I can
tell you this. I can tell you this.
I happen to be doing the Judy was tell
you about the theme weeks I would do it.
Speaker 2: Oh yeah he's doing a theme week. I
don't know if it's infrastructure or whatever.
And so what's the scariest thing about all of
this? The scariest thing about all of this is
that if you look at the real Clear Politics,
average Georgia Senate Walker versus Warnock,
you see that it is now a tie. If you look at
the last four polls, it's Walker plus one in
the right leaning Trafalgar Poll. Walker plus
two in an Emerson poll. Walker plus three in an
insider advantage poll and Warnock plus six
in a Quinnipiac poll. Now, I will tell you,
I believe the Quinnipiac poll is probably
the highest quality poll of the four. That's
the one that has Warnock winning. But this is
really scary stuff. The people of Georgia may
send a man who can't explain his views on any
issue to be one of 100 members of the Senate.
If you're listening today and you'd like to take
a look at those clips, I just played head on over
to our Instagram at David Pakman show, and you
can check out the full horror of those clips.